what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
things
are really starting to heat up for
spider-man no way home the trailer for
the film
is right around the corner today we have
more news and
proof that the trailer is about to drop
and if you've been following my videos
lately you know that total film magazine
today
released what they called a preview for
upcoming marvel films
this issue of total film magazine is
primarily about
loki which is about to come out on
disney plus in less than two weeks now
but in the article they included some
tidbits about other marvel
phase 4 films that are coming up pretty
soon and spider-man no way home was one
of them
side note thor love and thunder was also
one of them and apparently they're not
going to be doing the space sharks
anymore which is a pretty big bummer
taikawatiti said that there was a legal
issue so they can no longer use them but
we get a description for
14 different upcoming mcu projects
pretty much the entire phase four slate
in this issue of total film magazine so
i'll go over those
at the end but first we're going to talk
about spider-man no way home
and that trailer quick reminder only
three days left in my stormbreaker
giveaway to enter just subscribe to my
channel and cosmic culture will be
picking a winner on monday
so as far as spider-man no way home is
concerned we got
kind of a lot but also kind of a little
total film magazine advertised on the
very cover of their issue
a preview for upcoming marvel projects
spiderman no way home was one of them
and their preview is basically a little
synopsis of the film and the synopsis
is actually kind of weird and i'll
explain what i mean but first let's go
over it
it says spider-man no way home director
john watts starring tom holland zendaya
jamie foxx eta estimated time of arrival
17th of december 2021 and it says
after a lot of legal wrestling between
sony and marvel
tom holland is finally back in the mcu
for his third
solo outing past life baddies electro
jamie foxx and dr octopus alfred molina
are rumored
to return to a bigger broader
spider-verse that's now reeling from
peter parker's recent unmasking
so this kind of just makes me laugh
because at this point
this is the worst kept secret in
hollywood this issue of total film
magazine
is a partnership between total film and
marvel slash disney
they literally work together on this so
the fact that they're trying to say that
it's
rumored that elektro and dr octopus are
going to show up is pretty hilarious
because
we know that all they're trying to do is
make people second guess that maybe they
won't be in the film but
we know they are at this point because
both actors have confirmed this
this is literally marvel saying don't
say too much about the film
don't confirm the spider-verse we're not
going to do that yet
but try to get people excited so mention
the spider-verse but
also say that it's a rumor at this point
but honestly what's really the point now
i mean we know at this point in time
that it's going to be a spider-verse
film we know alfred molina is coming
back and we know jamie foxx is coming
back
but i commend them to sticking to it and
not really admitting it until the
trailer comes out
now the part at the end that is rather
interesting says these characters are
rumored to return to a bigger
broader spider-verse that's now reeling
from peter parker's recent unmasking
this almost makes it sound like the
spider-verse is being caused by the fact
that peter parker's identity has been
revealed and we know that that's not the
case the multiverse
isn't going to burst open just because
peter parker's identity has been
revealed or maybe it could maybe they
could make some type of weird storyline
out of it but we know that's not how
it's going to be
we know that loki is going to cause some
pretty big issues for the multiverse we
know that the snap
probably caused some big issues as well
and wanda probably is going to play some
part
instead what i think they're saying here
in this description is that these
characters are going to be
a part of a now bigger spider-verse and
they're going to find themselves in the
mcu
and the mcu right now is kind of in
chaos and the fact that peter parker's
identity has been revealed
makes it a little bit more chaotic
especially since we have
previous spider-man villains returning
who will most likely try to fight
spider-man and now they know who he is
and this is what they had to say for
their so-called preview
which really wasn't that much of a
preview so it's kind of weird that they
advertised it as such but it's not
really the first time that we've been
underwhelmed with spider-man no way home
info
but at the same time this just further
confirms the multiverse again they're
talking about all these
rumors but this was a collaboration with
marvel and disney so if marvel and or
disney did not want them to say
hey it's rumored that the spider-verse
is coming and these characters are going
to be in the film
then they'd tell them not to say that
now they are journalists and they are an
outlet so they could kind of write
whatever they wanted to
but again since they're kind of
partnered with sony and disney on this
you wouldn't want to upset them in any
way because then that relationship is
done
then the magazine would get no more
actor interviews or any information at
all from
marvel and disney about their upcoming
films so this is all in line with what
marvel and disney want it to be in line
with they gave them the okay to say
the spider-verse is rumored and to me it
just seems like they're just waiting for
the trailer to confirm
the spider-verse which makes sense they
want to be the ones who break
the news and speaking of that trailer
like i said we do have some news today
and it's good news and it looks like the
trailer
is happening soon i don't want to get
people's hopes up too much in case it
doesn't happen but that june
release date for the trailer is looking
pretty good right now
in a previous video i mentioned that
sony pictures germany account had
changed their background banner to the
spider-man no way home logo
and their official twitter account did
the same and now we have
even more sony youtube accounts changing
their banners to spider-man no way home
the banner has been changed on sony
pictures austria
sony pictures of vietnam and sony
pictures cambodia and this is big news
because this means that they are
preparing for the trailer to drop
they're preparing for the promotion of
the film to begin
which starts with the trailer i've said
this a couple of times but for those of
you who may not have heard it
you really don't start promotion on a
film unless a teaser trailer at
least has been released because the
general population won't know
anything about the film and it's really
hard to promote merchandise like shirts
and toys unless there's already some
type of preview for the movie out there
otherwise people just really won't know
so this
is a great sign that the trailer is
indeed about to drop and a lot of people
are looking at that june 1st release
date because it's tom holland's birthday
and considering the fact that it looks
like promotion
is about to ramp up for spider-man
norway home that is definitely a
possibility but
it is not confirmed so i would say don't
expect it on june 1st but if it happens
awesome now spiderman no way home isn't
the only synopsis that we got
the main article was obviously about
loki but they actually gave us a little
synopsis about all of the upcoming
marvel phase 4
projects now this is a spider-man video
so i'll keep it about spider-man but
tomorrow i'll do a
full breakdown of what each synopsis
says about for all of these films
including thor love and thunder
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness the marvels black panther
wakanda forever
the fantastic four ant-man and the wasp
quantomania
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and those
are all the movies and then of course
they have the disney plush shows coming
up
hawkeye miss marvel moon knight
she-hulk the guardians of the galaxy
holiday special
which they now have listed as an eta for
december 2022
and secret invasion which is also listed
for 2022 as well
and also says that it is starring amelia
clark
and for those happy gilmore fans out
there yesterday it was announced that
christopher mcdonald the actor that
played shooter mcgavin
is joining secret invasion as well so
after a pretty dark let's say a year and
a half of covet 19 and marvel kind of
put on hold it seems like everything is
rolling full
force right now it doesn't look like
we're going to be having any more delays
knock on wood and it looks like the
trailers for these films and shows
coming out on disney plus are just going
to start rolling out and the next one on
the list
is spider-man no way home and look out
for that in the next few weeks i'll
update you if i hear anything else about
when the trailer could drop
in the meantime don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you stay up to date on all of the
latest
mcu news don't forget to like the video
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me